Hi chào đón một lần nữa để invade.com tên của tôi là Adam ngày hôm nay.
Chúng ta sẽ nhìn vào một cái gì đó mà tôi nhận được hỏi
về tất cả các thời gian vì vậy tôi sẽ là tôi bị mất
Cap của tôi có,
OK, do đó, người học sinh. Hỏi tôi tất cả thời gian?
Sự khác biệt giữa mặc dù là gì,
mặc dù và thậm chí mặc dù và mặc dù bất chấp
rất đơn giản.
Nó không phức tạp như tất cả mọi người nghĩ đầu tiên.
Hãy bắt đầu với những 3.
Những 3, mặc dù, mặc dù và mặc dù chúng được sử dụng
với mệnh đề trạng từ.
Bây giờ chỉ để làm mới bộ nhớ của bạn?
Một điều khoản là gì là bất kỳ nhóm
từ đó có một chủ đề và một động từ nó phải
có một chủ đề và động từ.
Và 3 được sử dụng để hiển thị độ tương phản.
Vì vậy, những gì hiện tất cả điều này có nghĩa là nói chung,
bạn sẽ có một câu lâu dài câu này là
sẽ có 2 điều khoản.
Một khoản sẽ có điểm đánh dấu trạng từ này trong đó.
Các khoản khác sẽ là một khoản độc lập có nghĩa là nó
một câu mà có thể đứng của chính nó.
Và điều này không là nó cho thấy một sự tương phản hoặc một cái gì đó
đó là rất khác nhau từ một trong những điều khoản khác
như vậy trong đó một câu.
Bạn có những ý tưởng tương phản như tích cực và tiêu cực hoặc bạn
nghĩ rằng điều này sẽ xảy ra,
nhưng nó thực sự xảy ra,
một cái gì đó rất khác với những gì bạn mong đợi.
Mặc dù và bất chấp những giới từ.
Và chúng được sử dụng với một cụm từ bây giờ,
một cụm từ là gì một cụm từ cũng là một nhóm
của từ.
Nhưng nó không cần phải có một chủ đề trong một
động từ.
Nó có thể có một danh từ hoặc nó có thể có một
động từ hoặc nó có thể không có nhưng thường nó có
ít nhất một hoặc một gerund,
nhưng chúng tôi sẽ nhận được rằng,
nhưng nó cũng cho thấy độ tương phản.
OK, trước khi tôi cung cấp cho bạn một số câu ví dụ để hiểu
tất cả điều này,
hãy nhìn vào mỗi một cách riêng biệt,
mặc dù, và mặc dù sự khác biệt là những gì?
Không có sự khác biệt, Tuy nhiên, là một chút không chính thức hơn
bạn có thể sử dụng một trong hai lúc bắt đầu của một
câu hoặc giữa một câu.
Sự khác biệt lớn nhất là bạn có thể kết thúc một câu
với
mặc dù bạn có thể không thực sự kết thúc một câu với mặc dù và
một lần nữa khi bạn kết thúc một câu với,
mặc dù. Câu chính thức OK, vì vậy bạn phải giữ cho rằng
trong tâm trí,
để không chính thức. Bây giờ không có nghĩa là điều này là chính thức.
Nó chỉ có nghĩa là điều này là không chính thức nếu điều đó làm cho
bất kỳ ý nghĩa.
Bout ' làm thế nào mặc dù thậm chí mặc dù cũng cho thấy một độ tương phản
nhưng đó là một độ tương phản mạnh hơn nhiều nó thêm sự nhấn mạnh?
Nhưng sự nhấn mạnh vào OK là gì?
Điều gì là quan trọng? Sự nhấn mạnh được đặt trên các
kỳ vọng là gì?
Vì vậy, ví dụ, sự khởi đầu của câu có một
ý tưởng, do đó bạn nghĩ rằng điều này phải là phần thứ hai,
nhưng không có một cái gì đó rất khác nhau là phần thứ hai và
đây là một sự nhấn mạnh rất mạnh về kỳ vọng này.
Khi tôi cung cấp cho bạn một số câu ví dụ,
bạn sẽ hiểu những gì tôi đang nói về.
Dù và mặc dù trong số này là chính xác cùng
trừ một từ 3 từ cho một quyền này.
Nhưng họ làm việc. Các chính xác cùng một cách bạn có thể trao đổi
.
Một trong những sai lầm mà nhiều người làm họ nói trong mặc dù
của hay này?
Mặc dù một cái gì đó họ pha trộn chúng rất cẩn thận.
Mặc dù khuôn mặt của bạn. Mặc dù khuôn mặt của bạn không pha trộn.
2 lên. Có 2 những thứ khác nhau với cùng
có nghĩa là OK.
Điều này sẽ được nhiều rõ ràng hơn khi tôi đặt lên một số
ví dụ,
vì vậy hãy làm điều đó.
OK chúng ta hãy bắt đầu với mặc dù mặc dù,
và mặc dù tôi đã về cơ bản cùng một câu cho
cách khác nhau OK.
Mặc dù kỳ thi là khó khăn.
Tôi nghĩ rằng tôi đã làm tốt bây giờ ở đây.
Sự tương phản là giữa khó khăn và làm tốt đúng.
Đó là độ tương phản khó khăn có nghĩa là làm xấu.
Nhưng đây là một đối diện OK rất dễ dàng.
Tôi bắt đầu với mặc dù tôi sẽ cung cấp cho bạn những đối diện, vì
bạn là một chủ đề và đây là động từ của bạn và sau đó
đây là đối tượng của bạn và đây là động từ của bạn một lần nữa.
Chúng tôi muốn nói về các khoản phụ tại
cuối ở đó.
Đó là một trong những chính câu của bạn bây giờ tôi có thể chuyển đổi
nó xung quanh.
Tôi có thể nói. Tôi nghĩ rằng tôi đã làm tốt.
Mặc dù kỳ thi là khó khăn bắt đầu và không quan trọng.
Sự khác biệt duy chỉ sẽ là dấu phẩy.
Nếu bạn đặt này như là mệnh đề thứ hai.
Không có dấu phẩy nếu bạn bắt đầu một câu với các trạng từ
đánh dấu bạn có một dấu phẩy.
Tôi nghĩ rằng tôi đã làm tốt,
mặc dù kỳ thi là khó khăn.
OK. Vì vậy, đó là
sai lầm của tôi có xin lỗi về điều đó ở đây chúng tôi có nó
trong phần thứ hai tôi có thể đặt mặc dù ở đây,
tôi có thể đặt mặc dù ở đây,
cả hai sẽ là OK không thay đổi ý nghĩa của
câu.
Một là chỉ là không chính thức một chỉ là thường xuyên không có vấn đề.
Ở đây, những gì tôi đã làm là tôi muốn cho bạn thấy
làm thế nào để đặt nó vào cuối,
vì vậy tôi chia ra câu thành 2 kỳ thi
là khó khăn.
Giai đoạn câu đã hoàn tất. Tôi nghĩ rằng tôi đã làm tốt,
mặc dù. Bây giờ ở đây tôi đặt một dấu phẩy khi tôi đặt
hóa đơn với kết thúc bây giờ một lần nữa.
Điều này là không chính thức. Đây là những người như thế nào người ta nói đôi khi
bạn có thể có nó bằng văn bản,
nhưng không phải trong văn bản chính thức,
nhưng bạn thấy như thế nào tôi có thể đặt chúng tôi tại
kết thúc.
Tôi không thể đặt mặc dù ở đây mà không làm việc.
Bạn phải sử dụng nó,
mặc dù ở phần cuối của câu trong các tình huống không chính thức.
Bây giờ ở đây tôi thay đổi câu một chút thậm chí
mặc dù các kỳ thi đã được dễ dàng.
Tôi đã thất bại bây giờ, sự khác biệt ở đây là những gì?
Kỳ thi là khó khăn. Tôi nghĩ rằng tôi đã làm tốt như vậy
có một độ tương phản,
nhưng nó không phải là rất mạnh mẽ tương phản quyền.
Ở đây các kỳ thi đã được dễ dàng như vậy nếu tôi nghe
thi đã được dễ dàng.
Tôi hy vọng rằng bạn đã làm,
rất tốt bên phải. Đó là toàn bộ ý tưởng.
Nhưng tôi thất bại đó là quyết liệt mạnh có nghĩa là nó hoàn toàn khác nhau
kết quả hơn những gì tôi mong đợi.
Đó là lý do tại sao tôi đang sử dụng ngay cả khi mặc dù nó
được dễ dàng tôi đã thất bại.
Điều này không nên xảy ra. Sau này đúng như vậy sự khác biệt
là rất mạnh mẽ từ những kỳ vọng rằng bạn muốn
sử dụng mặc dù để nhấn mạnh.
Có vẻ như là sự khác biệt OK, tôi hy vọng tất cả mọi người hiểu rằng hơn
hoặc ít hơn.
Chính xác của họ trong hầu hết các tình huống.
Bạn có thể sử dụng bất kỳ một trong 3 nó sẽ không
làm cho rằng nhiều của một sự khác biệt.
Một trong những điều này có một cảm giác nhất định để nó.
Một sự khác biệt mạnh mẽ. Vì vậy, khi bạn đang viết một bài luận cho
ví dụ,
đôi khi nó sẽ tạo ra một sự khác biệt.
Mặc dù hoặc mặc dù nhưng thường không.
Hãy nhìn vào mặc dù bất chấp của OK.
Bây giờ hãy nhìn vào bất chấp và mặc dù như vậy
trước hết.
Những nỗ lực tốt nhất của ông, người đàn ông chỉ có thể không thành công.
Xin lỗi quên để đặt một khoảng thời gian ít,
có ở cuối, OK bây giờ đầu tiên?
Có nghĩa là nó có nghĩa là ông đã cố gắng tốt nhất của mình?
Ông đã cố gắng và cố gắng và cố gắng nhưng vẫn luôn thất bại
không bao giờ thành công bây giờ?
Những gì bạn nhận thấy về câu này ở đây?
Không có động từ quyền.
Nó chỉ là một cụm từ. Đây là những gì chúng tôi gọi là một
cụm từ này,
bạn có khoản của bạn thường xuyên độc lập với chủ đề của bạn và
động từ của bạn không có vấn đề.
Mặc dù những nỗ lực tốt nhất của mình,
người đàn ông chỉ có thể không thành công chính xác cùng một ý nghĩa OK
một biểu hiện này so với khác.
Một lần nữa, tôi có thể thay đổi nó xung quanh người đàn ông chỉ có thể không
thành công.
Bất chấp những nỗ lực tốt nhất của mình, người đàn ông chỉ có thể không thành công.
Mặc dù những nỗ lực của mình tốt nhất,
cùng, có nghĩa là một cách khác, chúng tôi có thể sử dụng mặc dù và trong
mặc dù là với một nhịp một động từ ing.
Điều này được gọi là một gerund.
Đó là một động từ ING, nhưng chúng tôi sử dụng nó giống như một danh từ
như vậy ở đây cụm từ này đang được về thời gian.
Để các bài giảng không quan trọng như vậy,
như vậy mặc dù về thời gian có nghĩa là,
mặc dù ông đã về thời gian nhìn thấy.
Tôi có thể làm cho một số lên.
Đó là chính xác cùng một ý nghĩa chúng tôi đã không thừa nhận chúng tôi đã
không được phép bên trong,
nên giữ trong tâm trí, mặc dù và trong mặc dù có nghĩa là
tương tự như mặc dù nhưng mặc dù bất cứ điều gì
chúng tôi sử dụng với cụm từ.
Mặc dù chúng tôi sử dụng với ' nguyên nhân.
Nếu không, cùng, có nghĩa là nếu bạn không chắc chắn và bạn vẫn
có một số câu hỏi,
xin vui lòng đi đến. Dot com có một bài kiểm tra có,
bạn có thể thử tất cả những điều này ra và yêu cầu của bạn
câu hỏi và tôi sẽ nhìn thấy bạn tiếp theo thời gian nhờ.